[Music]
um
dog
[Music]
is your internet being really slow
um
the irene committee members they are
members of the european parliament
they are journalists
i would like to welcome
francis hogan here in the european
parliament
thank you
for participating in this hearing
in this hearing the inco committee and
associated committees will listen to the
testimony of mrs
francis hogan an expert in algorithmic
product management and former employee
of facebook
miss hogan had disclosed thousands of
internal documents that she collected
while working for facebook
the purpose of the hearing is to enable
inco and associated committees to better
understand the challenges posed by
social media algorithms
to online user safety especially in the
context of the
digital services act
which intends to regulate the provision
of inter intermediary services and in
particular
to achieve a safe and trusted online
environment for users
firstly before
the hearing i would like to
ask
[Music]
the representatives of the other
committees
to take the floor for opening remarks
uh two minutes per committee
and
the first speaker in my list is adrian
vasquez lazara lazara
chair of jury committee please
is
yes
don't worry
but we have the technical questions uh
it's not uh only about
miss hogan but other people say that
there is no translation
first row is blocked
why
sorry we will try to fix this problem
and and i would like to ask you to
to start from the very beginning again
thank you
let's go
yeah
sorry for this but now it seems we can
can can start really so mr
lazara
the floor is yours please
is
thank you next i would like to ask
juan fernando lopez or elar to take the
floor
please juan
the floor is yours
thank you chair good afternoon mrs
huygen i'm talking to you in my capacity
as chair of the committee of liberty
just as a normal person of the european
parliament
which has been
engaged
for a number of years
by now in
making laws
on fundamental rights issues related
files and the protection of personal
data most particularly privacy of users
of platforms such as facebook
have therefore
been a relevant element of discussion
throughout the years
in the libya committee which i have the
honor to chair
of course we'll welcome you here your
testimony
in this hearing on the negative impact
on users of high-tech companies
products and business models
how eu digital rules can address these
issues
let me reassure you that
we are
very much engaged
in the discussions around the digital
services act and digital markets acts
providing an opinion on these matters
but the revelations that you have come
up with
are most troubling regarding the direct
impacts on users
but also a
not a potential an actual attack
on their fundamental rights
but this is not the first time we see
ourselves
facing this kind of situation
three years ago we put in place
a number of hearings on the abuses
discovered regarding cambridge analytica
proceedings and revelations
in its resolution at the time this
european parliament stated the data
analysis and algorithms have an
increasing impact i'm quoting on the
information made accessible to citizens
and that such techniques if misused and
they are actually misused i add may
endanger fundamental rights to
information as well as media freedom
and pluralism so your revelations
are confirming that we have reached
some kind of a high point a pick
where the fundamental rights
of users
are at stake we see the impact of these
algorithms exploiting mental health of
teenagers
micro targeting
and impinging on people fundamental
rights
but not only for commercial purposes but
also for political
political targeting political purposes
so as it appears by now
that self-regulation by the companies
themselves is failing utterly failing
the simple question would be
what is your assessment on the
revelation
on this uh
proceedings by by facebook
and
the kind of regulation safeguards that
you would like to see fit for the future
particularly at the disposal of the
european parliament field of action
would you think that the current
proposal at eu level
is something of relevance
according to your assessment as far as
you know are they sufficient the package
at site or anything else that could and
should be done thank you
thank you next i would like to ask a
rafael gluexman to take the floor please
democracy
poco
next i would like to ask
dragon studarash to take the floor
representing either committee
thank you very much
and thanks for associating aida also to
the to the hearing tonight
congratulations mrs hogan for the
courage to stand up for values that are
so important to to us as consumers as
individuals
i represent the special committee of
this house on artificial intelligence
and we spent in fact the last year
looking into the impact of ai and the
underlying algorithms powering ai with
the paramount will of this house to
ensure that the ai develops on the basis
of rules that protect human rights and
interests
your revelations are confirming many of
the concerns there i say fears
that for many of us in this house have
been
related to the practices by big
platforms particularly social media
platforms
dsa is already an ambitious starting
point introducing an obligation for risk
assessments on how platforms work
i think it is a good tool to address
systemic risk built into the algorithm
algorithms but in its current logic it
only concerns illegal content so
how do you think we could regulate
harmful content not yet passing the
threshold of illegality
and presuming you would have the rules
or that platforms such as facebook would
have the will to intervene by their own
volition
do you think you know expert knowledge
that algorithms can be reverse
engineered once they have grown into a
given direction thank you
thank you
and i would like to thank all the
committees
chairs for your opening remarks
the hearing will be organized as follows
first miss hogan will give a 15
minutes presentation then
there will be a q and a session
there will be two rounds of questions
and answers two-minute question
by members and two-minute answer by
miss hogan
and
now i would like to
ask miss hogan to take the floor for a
presentation
thank you
chair kazavi casa please
forgive my pronunciation on things um
honorable member members of the european
parliament thank you for the opportunity
to appear before you and for your
interest in confronting some of the most
urgent threats to the citizens of the
european union
my name is francis haugen
i used to work at facebook and joined
the company because i believe facebook
has the potential to bring out the best
in us
but i am here today because i believe
that facebook's products harm children
stoke division
weaken our democracy and much more
the company's leadership knows ways to
make facebook and instagram safer
but they won't make the necessary
changes because they have put their
immense profits before people
the consequences are severe
the facebook platform today damages the
health and safety of our communities and
threatens the integrity of our
democracies
rising to meet these challenges won't be
easy
but democracies must do what they have
always done
when the actions of commerce conflict
with the interests of the people and
society as a whole democracies must step
in and make new laws
i am grateful that the european union is
taking this very seriously
the digital services act that is now
before this parliament has the potential
to be a global gold standard
it can inspire other countries including
my own
to pursue new rules that would safeguard
our democracies
but the law has to be strong and its
enforcement firm
otherwise we will lose this once in a
generation opportunity to align the
future of technology and democracy
my analysis and explanation of the
documents in my disclosure
is grounded in more than the time i
spent at facebook
i have worked as a product manager at
large tech companies since 2006
including google pinterest yelp and
facebook
my job has largely focused on
algorithmic products like google plus
search and recommendation systems like
the one that powers the facebook news
feed
working at four major tech companies
that operate different types of social
networks
i have been able to compare and contrast
how each company
approaches and deals with different
challenges
the choices being made by facebook's
leadership are a huge problem
for children for public safety
and for democracy
that's why i came forward
and let's be clear it doesn't have to be
this way
we are here today because of deliberate
choices facebook has made
i joined facebook in 2019 because
someone close to me was radicalized
online
i felt compelled to take an active role
in
role in creating a better less toxic
facebook
during my time at facebook first working
as the lead product manager for civic
misinformation and later on counter
espionage
i saw that facebook repeatedly
encountered conflicts between its own
profits
and our safety
facebook consistently resolved these
conflicts in favor of its own profits
the result has been a system that
amplifies division extremism and
polarization
it undermines societies around the world
in some cases this dangerous online talk
has led to actual violence that harms
and even kills people
in other cases their profit optimizing
machine is generating self-harm and
self-hate
especially for vulnerable groups like
teenage girls
these problems have been confirmed
repeatedly by facebook's own internal
research
this is not simply a matter of some
social media users being angry or
unstable
facebook became
a facebook became a one trillion dollar
company
by by paying for its profits with our
safety including the safety of our
children
and that is unacceptable
i believe what i did was right and
necessary for the common good
but i know facebook has infinite
resources which you could use to destroy
me
i came forward because i recognized a
frightening truth
almost no one outside of facebook knows
what happens inside of facebook
the company's leadership keeps vital
information from the public
the us government
its shareholders and governments around
the world
the documents i have provided prove that
facebook has repeatedly misled us about
what its own research reveals about the
safety of children
its role in spreading hateful and
polarizing messages
and so much more
the right answer to this emergency is
new rules and standards
the eu's digital services act has a huge
potential
it does not try to delete this problem
with content regulations
it takes a content neutral approach
to address the systemic risks and harms
of the overall business model and i
strongly support this approach
there's much to say about this
legislation but i want to highlight
three issues that are critically
important based on my experiences
first
risk assessments and access to privacy
aware data streams
second comprehensive roles and standards
for the business model
third the danger of loopholes and
exemptions i'll address these three in
turn
at the core of the problems we face
right now is that no one can understand
facebook's destructive choices better
than facebook because only facebook gets
to look under the hood
facebook cannot remain the judge jury
prosecutor and witness
so a critical starting point for
effective regulation is transparency
full access to data for research not
directed by facebook
we need more experts studying these
problems and they must have all the data
they need to do it
it is critical to get this right and the
devil will be in the details
for example if you write a broad
exemption for transparency for anything
classified as a trade secret
the companies will say everything is a
trade secret
facebook would still operate in the dark
continuing to make choices that go
against the common good
so i believe researchers should respect
trade secrets once they have received
proprietary data but trade secrets can
and should not be an excuse for
companies to refuse access to data
access to data is the starting point
it's what permits researchers and
regulators to assess risks and harms of
the whole system of profiling targeting
and engagement based ranking
the evidence in my disclosures to the
sac make clear that engagement based
ranking systems are one of the root
causes for some of the greatest systemic
risks that social media poses to our
societies
this is a system level problem
this is why new rules must not be
limited to illegal content but must also
include the recommendation of content
that violates the platform's terms and
conditions
using content neutral tools the dsa
should force platforms to take
responsibility for the risks beyond the
spread of illegal content
such as manipulation of elections the
explosive spread of disinformation or
the harms of teenage mental health
the heart of this legislation lies in
the strength of articles 26 and 27.
this brings me to my third point
i have read with great interest their
efforts to exempt news media content
from the rules of the dsa
but if you're going to make content
neutral rules then they must really be
neutral
nothing is singled out and nothing is
exempted
let me be very clear
every modern disinformation campaign
will exploit news media channels on
digital platforms by gaming the system
if the dsa makes it illegal for
platforms to address these issues we
risk undermining the effectiveness of
the law
indeed we may be worse off than today's
situation
if you get the dsa right for your
linguistically and ethnically diverse
450 million eu citizens
you can create a game changer for the
world
you can force platforms to price in
societal risk to their business
operations so the decisions about what
products to build
and how to build them is not purely
based on profit maximization
you can establish systemic rules and
standards that address risks while
protecting free speech
and you can show the world how
transparency
oversight and enforcement should work
let's not forget
we have stood at these crossroads before
when tobacco companies claimed that
filtered cigarettes were safer for
consumers
it was possible for scientists to
independently invalidate
that
this marketing message
because it was just a marketing message
and confirmed that in fact they still
posed a serious threat to human health
they were actually in fact more toxic
than unfiltered cigarettes but today we
can't make this kind of independent
assessment of facebook
we have to just trust facebook says what
facebook says is true and they have
repeatedly proved they do not deserve
our blind faith
trust is earned it's not just given
facebook's regulators can see some of
these pro can see some of the problems
but they are kept blind what's causing
them and thus can't craft specific
solutions
they can't even access the company's own
data on product safety much less conduct
an independent audit
how is the public supposed to assess if
facebook is resolving conflicts of
interest in a way that is aligned with
the public good if it has no visibility
and no context into how facebook really
operates
this must change
dear members of dear members of
parliament
there is a lot at stake here
you have a once in a generation
opportunity to create new rules for our
online world
a safer more enjoyable social media is
possible
if there are only two things that
everyone takes away from these
disclosures it should be
first facebook chooses profit over
safety every day and without bold action
from lawmakers
this will continue
the second is that facebook has
exploited its ability to hide the actual
behavior of the platform to allow our
safety decay to an unacceptable level
if facebook is allowed to continue to
operate in darkness we will only see
escalating tragedies as a result
i came forward at great personal risk
because i believe we still have time to
act
but we must act now
thank you
[Applause]
thank you miss hogan for your
presentation and now we can start with
the q and a session first i would like
to ask andres fob from etp group to take
the floor please andres yeah
thank you andreas
miss hogan please
sorry my apologies so that's a lot to
address in two minutes but i'll do my
best with regard to the risk to
democracies um
one of the so the inherent danger in
engagement based ranking and mark
zuckerberg has said this specifically he
has said in 2018 even engagement based
ranking is dangerous because people are
drawn to engage with extreme content
more than le than more mainline content
when that happens
effectively we give a much much much
much larger fraction of the public forum
to the most extreme the most polarizing
the most divisive content
this also happens in ads because ads
that get more engagement are cheaper
running an angry hateful divisive
political campaign will be five to ten
times cheaper than running one that is
about empathy and compassion
democracies cannot exist if we can't see
each other as human beings if we can't
have empathy and and solidarity with
each other
and so i believe that having a system
that amplifies a divisive content like
that will erode our democracies the
second question is around
what can we do with regard to regulating
private economy um
and uh and and
in a way that is um
uh
i'm trying to hit both freedom of
expression that we may not get there um
so i'm a strong proponent of what i call
one two three risk assessments so
companies should assess themselves but
there should also be some party that can
gather feedback from the community
because facebook is very homogeneous it
largely speaks english it's largely
isolated in california at least those
who are making
most decisions
and unless you go and survey civil
society groups you're not going to get a
full picture
the three is facebook should have to
articulate how it will solve those harms
because it has gotten into a rut where
every time something is exposed all they
do is say we're so sorry this is really
hard we're working on it we need to
change our relationship with these
platforms where they have to actually
articulate what the plan is for fixing
them
and they should have to disclose
aggregate privacy conscious
privacy sensitive data so that we can
independently see are they actually
making progress
on those concerns um i think that is
probably the most flexible way of
regulating a private company
because it can happen and be dynamic
over and over again the concerns of
today and the concerns of five years ago
will be different concerns and as long
as we have that kind of
framework where the community's
involvement is in place in addition to
um
the needs of just the company i think
there's a way of covering more of those
issues
thank you
now i would like to ask christopher
schulte morris to take the floor please
thank you so much and uh a great thanks
to you miss haugen for being here today
uh i'm really happy that you took our
invitation and came it's very timely for
the work we do on on the dsa
and i agree with you that this is a
historic moment we have a chance we have
a historic opportunity to do something
for
regulating and maybe take back control
to society from the big tech
companies
thank you for your all your statements i
would like to discuss a little bit about
how we modernize the liability
rules you also said it in the congress
that you know
in united states you have section 230
and
giving the tech companies uh
immunity from civil liability and we
have the same in the e-commerce they are
exempted from liability the platforms
but when you talk about one two three
you kind of send the signal that you
want the platforms to become
liable accountable for their algorithms
and how they work so could you maybe uh
give us your suggestions on how we could
make them liable or accountable at least
because i think this is this is key of
course they should not be liable for
what i put on facebook but how they use
what i put on facebook i think that
could be important for them to to be so
that i would be happy to to hear
about
that
and i think that's the most important
thing so i will give you more time to
answer instead of using all my time
thank you
thank you crystal
please
miss holden
the question of how to increa increase
the accountability of these platforms is
a very important one
one of the things that i think is
essential is
my understanding is today there's no
there's really no practical way to bring
a class action lawsuit either in the
united states or in europe partially
because we don't have a way of seeing
differential harms
when you think about mandatory data
there are ways to segment the population
that are privacy sensitive i worked on
some of these
where you
produce a
cohorts and you can report stats in an
aggregated way on differential harms per
population
so what we found in the case of coveted
misinformation was that four percent of
the population received 80 percent of
all the coveted misinformation
this is not a novel problem it is a
problem that repeats itself with every
harm type
so i think one thing is if you want to
hold the platforms accountable for say
some children being overexposed to
self-harm content there has to be a way
for us to get information on those
constant that concentration of harm
because like i said every harm type has
these kinds of problems because of how
the algorithms push people towards
homogeneity
i think the second question on liability
is around um responsibility i'm a strong
proponent that uh so one of the repeated
things we hear from facebook is that no
one can no person can be held
accountable for any decision that
happens on the platform the committees
of people decide everything
i think requiring that a name should be
associated with every change would
actually radically change the culture of
facebook
because today people hide behind that
that unified front
and it means that no one stands up for
what's right because no one will ever
have it traced back to them
i think the last question is around
things like executive liability
i am relatively agnostic on executive
liability i think it amplifies the
effect of any law that you pass so if
you feel really confident in the law
that you've passed then
executive liability can be a good thing
um or at least makes them take it a lot
more seriously
but at the same time if the law is not
good it can cause counter effects and
side effects so i'm i'm not a lawmaker i
i'm it's probably beyond my scope to
weigh in on that
thank you next i would like to ask tita
schwarzola to take the floor
peter the floor is yours please thank
you very much mr chair and thank you mrs
hogan
you worked at a unit for civic integrity
as you mentioned and you also said in
one of your interviews that dissolving
that unit was the sign that facebook
was not interested in fighting this
information
and the digital services act which i
understand you you read here and you you
are aware of all the details we have now
different articles both on risk
assessment mitigation of risks
independent audit enforcement mechanism
so it would make actually mandatory that
facebook would have such a unit and
action will have to act against this
information and harmful content which is
something to my knowledge which is not
required and is not a proposal in the us
but at the same time in our proposal as
it is drafted it will be still facebook
itself that will choose the ways how to
mitigate the risk
do you think this is a good approach or
do you think we should have perhaps
national regulators to
micromanagement
manage such a massive complex system
thank you
thank you miss hogan please
i feel fairly strongly that the role for
regulators is to make sure that facebook
has to
follow at least a certain amount of the
rules of the road so this is less so a
thing of saying you must do x y z in
terms of how to change your platform but
is more so you know if we have like a
one two three approach that they have to
you know take an input from lots of
community groups in a way that is not
filtered by facebook itself or that they
have to report on statistics that would
allow us to see have they actually made
progress on what they said was the
solutions
um i'm a strong proponent also for for
criteria on what is a rigorous enough
solution like it has to be a good faith
plan on how will you solve these things
i think it is it will be difficult to
have a regulator that mandates specific
exchanges partially because any time you
draw a fence companies figure out how to
run around the fence
and so having something dynamic like a
risk assessment process is important
but the secondary thing is i i feel
strongly that part of why
regulators should be gathering that have
forcing platforms to disclose that data
or forcing them to disclose their harms
publicly is right now people never get a
fair chance to assess if they want to
use these products
right facebook because they have misled
us over and over again
people's dignity is being violated
because they are exposed to harms that
they are told don't exist
right and that's not that's not fair or
just
um
i do i also think that if you have
auditors that are paid for by facebook
you will run into problems with um
they will auditors will want to get
hired again and if they are paid by
facebook they will likely not do as
thorough job as is necessary um so
having the ability for the public to see
risk assessments is actually quite
important for consumers to be able to uh
have informed choices
thank you
next uh i would like to ask alexandra
gaza to take the floor please
thank you chair and thank you mr hogan
for being here today for coming forward
i think i can speak on behalf of almost
all my colleagues saying that we're
extremely grateful to you for that and
you're doing that at a great personal
risk and we really appreciate
i have two questions um you have
stressed the importance of access to
data for civil society do you think the
current wedding in the dsa which under
certain circumstances allows for access
for vetted academic researchers only
is enough
or do you think we should also give
access to ngos and investigative
journalists for example under certain
conditions and you might want to outline
those conditions and those processes
that's the first question and my second
question is
you have been an advocate for strong
regulation that is needed to make sure
facebook doesn't continue to harm
society but we all know that regulation
needs to be enforced to be effective
what kind of enforcement do you think we
need will national oversight and 27
member states be able will those
agencies be able to recruit enough
experts or do you think a european
enforcement agency with a strong center
of competence for systemic risks should
be established would that be a way to
make sure that the dsa really has teeth
and that europe could become a beacon
for the world and digital regulation
thank you so much
thank you miss hogan please
i think this question does a great job
of highlighting the importance of having
an ecosystem
of of both analysts and ecosystem of
people proposing solutions is so
important
so the first question is around
giving data to vetted academic
researchers and like whether or not that
circle is broad enough
just so people have context in the case
of twitter which is substantially more
transparent than facebook there's
something called a fire hose and the
fire hose contains one tenth of all the
tweets that appear on on twitter
there are easily 10 to 20 000 analysts
around the world that analyze this
public data
and because they have access to it they
find things like influence operations
information operations being run by
foreign actors like russia
a huge fraction of those operations that
exist on facebook
were caught not on facebook they were
caught on twitter
and when people looked at those accounts
they found identical accounts on
facebook
if facebook had to like i i strongly
encourage you to not just give data to
academics because the population of
incredibly competent people who are
experts in the space exist outside of
academia and they exist outside of
government and they will continue to do
so
we need to build that ecosystem of
having of of people building the muscle
to understand facebook if we want to be
safe
and they often are very novel like they
find different strategies that are are
not yet um
maybe have have reached academia
the second question is around whether or
not enforcement and actually just add
one thing on there i i would love to do
commentary if i had data right i am not
an academic i probably won't get
accepted i'm not gonna be a professor
probably um but you want to be able to
have people like me who have the
expertise from inside companies to then
illustrate patterns with public data the
last question is on um member states um
so just to be super super blunt here the
number of experts formal experts in
these things so i think this is how the
algorithms really work and the
consequences of them there are very very
few in the world because you can't get a
master's degree in it you can't get a
phd in it you have to go work for one of
these companies and be trained up
internally and i sincerely worry that if
you
delegate this functionality to 27 member
states you will not be able to get
critical mass in any one place
like i think it's a it'll be very very
difficult to get enough experts and
distribute them that broadly
there are definitely people who have
worked in industry who really want to
give back by contributing to public
accountability
and so having a home for them i think is
important having a place where they can
cross-pollinate to academia and other
outlets but having a home is going to be
really important
thank you next i would like to ask
alexandre passo to take the floor
grazie president
gentiles
thank you miss hogan please
um one of facebook's most common
refrains in response to me has been uh
it makes no business interest to design
a system that intentionally spreads
misinformation or spreads polarizing
content
and the reality is uh it's not a
question that they were deliberate in
designing these systems to do these
things it is
a question that it was deliberate that
they did not change them once they
discovered that a side effect of their
choices was to spread more
misinformation or more division
there are many possible changes
many of them content neutral
to reduce the amount of misinformation
division divisive content i'll give you
a couple examples
uh you could require clicking on a link
before you reshare it
that reduces misinformation
substantially you could make reshare
chains shorter you could say you know
after you get beyond friends of friends
if you want to re-share it at that point
you need to copy and paste it and and
you can totally share whatever you want
like we're not oppressing you we're not
judging your ideas we're just saying
make an intentional choice if you want
to spread it further that has the same
impact as the entire third party fact
checking system in terms of reducing
misinformation only
it works for all languages in the world
or things like facebook knows if they
show you more content from your family
and friends for free you get less
misinformation less division less
polarization so yes facebook knows lots
of ways to change the system but it
chooses not to because it will grow less
you'll consume less content
you'll
consume less ads they'll make less money
with regard to
having more representative views
i think as long as there is engagement
based ranking it is likely that the
system will continue pulling people
towards polarization facebook has run
the same experiment over and over again
where they have a brand new account
no friends no interest and they they
follow just a few
mainline interests so maybe their center
right or their center left and the thing
that happens every time or it's things
like healthy eating and every time if
you just engage with the recommendations
facebook gives you
it keeps getting more and more extreme
you know in the case of politics it
leads to content about killing your
opposition or white genocide you know
crazy ideas
for
that healthy eating one it leads you to
anorexia content so there's a real thing
of we need to
be thinking about
it's not bad people or bad ideas
it's about a system that is biased
towards spreading the most extreme ideas
that's the real problem and then lastly
with regard to the norwegian law i'm not
familiar with this and i don't know what
modified means um so i'm unfortunately i
can't comment on it but i'm happy to
later
thank you
the next speaker is cosmos lotovsky
cosmo
[Music]
foreign
thank you cosmo
miss hogan please
thank you
um
so i'm going to bend more towards the
bottom and go kind of upwards um so i
think this question of is facebook
different is a really important question
facebook is substantially less
transparent than other large platforms
and i think that plays out in that they
make less responsible decisions as a
result so i'll give you a concrete
example google knows their results can
be downloaded and that people analyze
them and as a result uh they they take
action they remove toxic content
because they know that people are
watching
um they also staff engineers who work on
search to explain search to people
twitter knows that people are analyzing
the twitter twitter
what tweets are getting distributed i
think they're more accountable and more
responsible as a result and so there is
a real tie between transparency and the
decisions and optimizations that these
platforms make
the question around encroaching on
freedom of speech is very very important
to me
i don't believe that focusing on
content-based solutions is sufficient
because uh every time you make a
decision that is about content you now
need to have a system that can intervene
in the 5 000 languages that exist on
earth you have to re-tune and rebuild
the ai over and over and over again
and that and facebook hasn't right it's
actually harder to support the third
largest language in ethiopia than it is
to english because the training systems
the the contractors that we would use to
be able to do that um
don't exist those services don't exist
so we need to think about how we make
systematic changes around amplification
how we make social media that is more
about our family and friends because we
like we liked social media when it was
about our family and friends right i'm
not asking you to give up social media
i'm asking you to have human scale
social media
um
i'll give you an example of um an
intervention that would radically
decrease misinformation if you said if
you have more than 5000 members in a
group you have to turn on self
moderation
as someone who ran a group that had 3
000 people i know that's hard i know
that less content would get out there
and if we know that one of them the most
dangerous kind of amplification levers
is half a million million person groups
those groups can still exist if their
members are so committed to their groups
that they're willing to staff the
moderators but with great power comes
great responsibility if you have a
medium that can blast out a message to a
million people
you know having some constraints and
saying hey like maybe you should
moderate for yourself the content
i think is an important thing
um the last question is around are these
things deliberate and as i mentioned
before
i don't believe they deliberately set
out to make a polarization engine
but they have known for years they've
known since at least 2018 that political
parties in europe were saying we are
running more polarized extreme ideas at
least on social media because that's the
only thing that gets distributed like if
we share a white paper on our
agricultural policy
we get crickets now we used to at least
get distribution
and i worry that by the time we reach
the ballot box
the options that we even get to choose
have been constrained by facebook
because
if the entire time you were only able to
run extreme ideas or give that the most
voice have you really been given a
choice to vote for
for for like what would reflect your own
needs because it's already been filtered
by facebook's algorithm
so society and and technology are now
intertwined in a way that they've never
been intertwined before
thank you next i would like to ask
martin scherzwan to take the flow
martin yes thank you chair and thank you
miss horn for being with us today on
forbearing testimony
on behalf of the left group in the
european parliament i just want to tell
you that we admire your courage to stand
up against facebook and to reveal its
business practices
that driven obviously by profit interest
are harmful for consumers free choice
toxic for the mental health of miners
and after all also dangerous for
democracy
as such uh your insight in the dealings
of facebook's facebook comes at the
crucial time as you know we are as
european lawmakers now working on a
hopefully strong regulation for big tech
and working on reining in their
monopolistic position related harmful
business models and let me just add very
briefly two more aspects to what has
been said
so far
firstly i'd like to know if you have
ever gained knowledge of decisions taken
by the facebook management or maybe even
by mark zuckerberg personally that were
tailor-made when it comes to the
european union have there been decisions
taken with special focus on elections
taking place in the european union or
elsewhere in europe any decisions
targeting in particular european
consumers and if so what were these
decisions and secondly
i'm personally in favor of a ban
of targeted advertisement i think a
business model based on the exploitation
of sensitive data such as political or
sexual orientation or
health related data is not only immoral
i think it should be illegal do you
think that there is a place in the
future digital
market for businesses that thrive
through the exploitation of personal
data thank you very much
thank you martin miss hogan please
um
i am not aware of any actions that were
specifically taken with the european
union in mind
other than i know that germany was
considered a quote at-risk country um
during their elections um during the
lead-up to it
i don't know this for sure but i'm
pretty sure
the reason why germany was given that
privilege
were those extra resources was because
they feared things like the dsa right
the other countries on the atlas that
were tier one and the at-risk countries
are places where
you know there's people actively killing
each other um and so it shows that
facebook invests resources for safety
not based on
equity right every election in europe is
important they should all get
supervision with regard to influence
operations or things like that
facebook should have to staff enough
security personnel that that's possible
because right now those functions are
all hidden and how much they're willing
to invest in those is hidden
um
with regard to targeted ads
i'm a strong proponent that people
should be allowed to make choices with
regard to how they are targeted and i
encourage
prohibiting dark dark patterns that
force people into opting into those
things
platforms should have to be transparent
about how they use that data and i'm a
big proponent of it there's a lot um
they should have to also publish
policies like
do they give flat ad rates for all
political ads because you know we
shouldn't be subsidizing hate in
political ads
um with regard to will there be
businesses that can be successful
without exploiting data
i strongly believe that facebook will
not be dislodged from what i call
personal social media so there's
broadcast social media which is things
like tick tock people create on tick
tock because they want to reach the
largest audience possible the market
works for things like tick tock and you
see lots of tick tock clones youtube has
one snapchat has one instagram has one
um but you don't see clones of facebook
and the reason for that is in personal
social media people create because they
want to reach very specific people and
unless you move the entire front network
somewhat simultaneously that's not going
to happen
and we can talk about interoperability
but it's outside the scope of this
question i don't think interoperability
will work and so in a world where um
it is almost impossible to escape that
center of mass you know three years ago
even there were still some countries
that had alternative personal media
now there are there really aren't any
countries except for china because they
banned facebook um and so i
i
i think there is a space for companies
that are more just with information
but we're not gonna we've we've lost the
chance for that world facebook is
personal social media and will be for
the foreseeable future
thank you next i would like to ask maria
marisa matthias to take the floor please
i'm going to speak in portuguese
i'm here in your left hi
foreign
thank you miss hogan please
um
before i dive into my answer i'll do a
quick plug for whistleblower protections
um
we will only need whistleblowers more in
the future right unless we have
substantially more transparency into
technology as a whole and remember the
dsa is going to cover platforms online
it's not going to cover
self-driving cars it's not going to
cover other systems that might be
harmful
it is extremely important to make sure
that there are protections and avenues
for whistleblowers of all levels to feel
safe coming forward because technology
is only going to accelerate and become
more dangerous
the second question is around automatic
control systems
i am extremely skeptical on ai being the
solution
this is because it is very difficult to
like ai is not actually intelligent
it is uh i've heard the metaphor that ai
is like having a million first graders
solve a problem if a million first
graders together can solve it ai will be
great for you but if it requires context
and understanding of a larger sphere ai
is very bad at that and we see this over
and over again in facebook's own
documents things like counterterrorism
speech being consistently labeled
terrorism speech
and that's because the words are similar
they don't understand the nuance in the
context
i'm a strong proponent that facebook
should have to disclose all of its
safety systems in terms of you know are
you looking for terrorism content are
you looking for self-harm are you
looking for hate speech what are those
systems and they should have to disclose
which languages they exist in and they
should have to disclose the performance
of those systems per language because
the reality is even when they say they
employ they implement it in something
other than english often they don't do a
good job of having actually be
performant
and so requiring things like disclosing
a thousand samples at each score
percentile would give us an ability to
come and say wow your terrorism detector
is stripping all the counterterrorism
out
and you see this over and over again in
the case of myanmar you know i was asked
by a journalist who had read through the
documents he said how is it possible
that there is no misinformation
classifier in myanmar like a system for
labeling what is misinformation that's
because facebook hasn't really invested
in third-party fact checking there like
it's difficult for them to have a
misinformation classifier
so this question of you know can
automatic systems be the solution i
think you have to make these platforms
smaller more human scale
slower
because that will automatically reduce a
lot of the harmful content and if you
focus on these automatic systems they
will not work for the the most
ethnically diverse places in the world
with linguistically diverse places in
the world which are often the most
fragile i guarantee you there's a lot of
languages even in europe that have no
safety systems or they have a very
minimal number of safety systems for
this reason
the last question on individual
responsibility
i'm a strong proponent of every change
should have to have a name associated
with it because facebook has hidden
behind
its collaborative culture
to remove responsibility from anyone
they say committees make the choices not
individuals
and even the action of saying you just
have to have a name on each change
because someone needs to be able to
stand up and say i believe in this thing
because today like that culture of the
lack of accountability means people also
don't push back
they just go with the flow
thank you and next i would like to ask
oxel who was to take the floor hogsel
the floor is your place
thank you but i would also like to
speak in german
[Music]
with regard to the change
of name for facebook from facebook to
meta
i am extremely concerned about meta and
the metaverse
partially because i think it illustrates
a meta problem of facebook which is they
really like to move on they really like
to gr prioritizing growth and expansion
over being actually finishing what they
build like making sure it's safe and
responsible so the fact that they can
afford ten thousand more engineers to
build video games
when they allegedly can't afford to have
10 000 engineers working on our safety i
find that unacceptable and i find it
unconscionable
um with regard to what the direct harms
will be of of metaverse not just these
you know you know zero-sum things um i
am very concerned about having lots and
lots more sensors in our homes and our
offices
because like to do a lot of metaverse
stuff you have to actually expose
yourself a lot more and facebook has
demonstrated that they lie
any time it's useful to them
and so the idea that we're supposed to
fill our homes and offices with lots
more sensors from a corporation that is
not transparent and like we have no
transparency into i think is a bad idea
along with that in the case of
workplaces at least like people often
don't get to opt in on what technology
is used by their employer so if someone
says hey i've read up on this i don't
feel safe having facebook have even more
data on me
if your employer says oh well we're a
metaverse company like you have to
accept this is how we do voice you know
how we do meetings
you don't there's no consent there and i
think that also is dangerous
um the only thing that i am excited
about metaverse is i think it is much
more human skill
so most of the interactions are at the
level of one to maybe 10.
um i think vr becomes pretty
overwhelming beyond that point
um and and that's a great illustration
of systems that are just intrinsically
safer like your uncle can have really
out there views and he might ruin
thanksgiving but he's not getting a
megaphone to a million people
right so by default when you design
human scale systems you get for free
less spread of extreme ideas
um with regard to
uh blocking more um
[Music]
blocking too much free expression um i i
that's part of why i'm saying we need to
have
samples like for any safety system they
we should be allowed to see a thousand
samples at various different scores
because i think we would be really
shocked at how much good content gets
thrown in with the bad content
especially on things like
counterterrorism versus terrorism
so i'm much more a proponent of how do
we design systems to be safe
um versus how do we touch the content a
lot because like i said before i don't
believe um content-based solutions scale
to the most fragile places in the world
then the last question around
balance balanced on teen advertising i
think it's a really hard thing because
right now facebook claims that they
don't target ads like that on teenagers
like you can you can say i want to reach
you know women who are between 13 and 16
or whatever um but the reality is ai
learns biases and ai learns things about
you
even if you're not aware that it's in
those systems like they're going to
learn keywords in those ads and it's
gonna act like targeting on vulnerable
teenagers and so um i think there are
ways that you can do that in terms of um
having it be a little bit more like tv
you know where ads are blasted out to a
much more diverse and less confined
audience but as long as ai can learn
those relationships it's going to micro
target
thank you the next speaker is tom van
der gren
thank you the floor is yours please
thank you chair and thank you miss hogan
first of all also from myself thank you
for being here uh it's not only very
courageous but in a way it's also
necessary because facebook to us
functions like a factory with with
closed factory with big concrete walls
and you're right the digital services
act will oblige them to put at least
some windows in those big concrete walls
they will be obliged to provide insight
into the processes of the algorithms
that determine what we see and why we
see it and that's an important first
step but i think
it it should not stop there it's
unacceptable like you said that
instagram for example would encourage
eating disorders among teenage girls or
that right-wing voters are pushed
towards extreme right-wing groups via
the algorithm without them actually even
realizing it now my question's on
algorithms the first
one which i want to ask you is how we as
lawmakers with limited knowledge and
resources can get a grip on the
algorithms of specialized tech giants
how do we ensure that we always stay one
step ahead especially because those
algorithms will continue to evolve also
second question concerns the input for
algorithms because as i understand it
facebook collects the data of its users
on a large scale and then uses these
same data to manipulate these users
themselves
cynical if you ask me it raises
questions about privacy and about what a
data company may use to build their
algorithm so that's why i would like to
know from you whether um we should set
limits on the data that facebook might
collect on the data that facebook might
collect and use as inputs for algorithms
would a restriction in this way of our
solution and if so what data should we
keep out of the algorithm i look forward
to your answers thank you
thank you miss hogan please
and with regard to this question of how
can lawmakers stay one step ahead
especially when these systems change so
much like that's part of why having
dynamic systems like the one two three
safety audits is so important um because
the reality is any fence you put up now
like anything we say you can't use these
three things in reality we need to be
able to continually evolve because these
systems evolve so fast
i think that's a also a reason why
facebook should have to disclose what
data goes into things like their ad
targeting algorithms or into how they
rank the news feed right being able to
disclose like these are the factors that
were used to prioritize content is
important
i'm a strong proponent that if facebook
has a fire hose like we discussed at
least for for some fraction of the
content um
they should have to disclose what those
scoring parameters were because if you
allowed people like independent
researchers and academics to have access
to it they would be able to summarize
for you what are the factors that are
disproportionately amplifying the worst
content
and the reality is right now a very
small number of people inside of
facebook are asking that question
because these things are very
complicated right when facebook says
that they're accurate um to give you a
sense of how limited our resource for
people who can even analyze these
problems like i'm not i'm not trying to
brag here i think there's probably on
the order of 200 or maybe 300 people in
the world who have the depth of
awareness that i do around how these
systems work and i think that alone is a
national security problem like we we
need to figure out ways where we can get
more eyes on these systems because right
now many of those people who fall in
that category are alumni of facebook or
the alumni of a place like google
and we have to figure out ways where
they can continue to be in the
conversation because part of why a lot
of those people left was because they
didn't get to work on keeping people
safe enough
with regard to um
like inputs for these systems and i
think as we have visibility into how
they currently use the data we will
realize data that we feel uncomfortable
having in there um and that's part of
why we need to involve not just
facebook's own perception of its its
harms we need to allow community members
say hey i feel really uncomfortable
about whatever parameter is being used
there because i guarantee you civil
society groups will have very different
opinions than facebook will
thank you next i would like to ask
natalie lazor to take the floor
please
foreign
and
with regard to does facebook does social
media be just restarted from the
beginning the reality is that facebook
has many tools at its disposal which it
has chosen not to use that are content
agnostic it doesn't require us to pick
good people or good ideas
like these are uh
these are systems that make this
platform slower that give people more
time to think before they re-share and
that has the side effect of less
misinformation that that those ideas
that are when you knee-jerk share them
uh they often but you went if you
thought about a little bit that it slows
those down
um some examples are things like i
talked about before of like having to
click a link before you reshare it or
cutting reshare chains um but there are
other things like um
[Music]
and
demoting content that is not from
someone you know right even demoting a
little because the worst things that
spread misinformation are how facebook
has pushed people into groups
um that are large that act like viral
variant factories you know a group that
has a million members and produces a
thousand pieces of content a day that is
the pro the biggest problem because
right now the algorithm picks three of
those pieces of content and spreads them
out to a million people but
unfortunately the algorithm
differentially picks they can it's
biased towards polarizing divisive
content
so a lot of these things if facebook was
required to do a risk assessment
they had to listen to the community and
they had to articulate how they were
going to get better and what data would
allow you to hold them accountable they
actually were getting better
they would likely fall back on some of
these things because for a lot of these
things they don't lose that much profit
they lose slivers like less than one
percent because it's true that people
consume a little less content when it's
safer
but the platform is also a lot nicer
they might actually be more profitable
in five years or ten years because more
people would still be on the platform a
lot of people are quitting because it's
toxic
but once you have that transparency once
you have to articulate how we're going
to deal with these problems it becomes
people inside the company get the space
to actually do the right things because
right now there is lots and lots of
weight pulled towards what's good for
the shareholders and there's not a
countervailing force that gives space
for people who want to do the right
thing to do the right thing
um with regard to having to publish what
content is taken down i think that's a
great idea because you would learn and
you have to do it by type like it was
taken down and why because immediately
you would learn that lots of stuff is
not being taken down in a variety of
languages you'd be like oh interesting
you're not actually doing integrity
actions in
xyz language
so anything that involves linguistic
transparency i think is vitally
important because right now facebook is
differentially harming
on
people who don't speak english and
that's unacceptable
um the last question is like how do they
distinguish between various forms of
content they use ai systems that allow
them to classify to label those those
things
and the quality is widely divergent
between languages so again if the way
that they are able to keep these
platforms safe is with these ais they
should have to publish enough data that
we feel confident that they are
investing they are being equitable in
safety because right now they're
investing in safety in the united states
because they're afraid of being
regulated but they're not investing in
safety in places that they aren't afraid
thank you next uh i would like to ask
ava maitel to take the floor please
thank you very much uh chair miss haugen
thank you for your testimony here today
and for being with us um i think
if we take
many messages from you i think one
message you probably can take away with
you is that we've heard you we hear you
very well and
i think
it's so brave but also extremely helpful
what you've been doing
over the past couple of weeks together
with many of my colleagues here i also
work on the digital single market and
the digital
markets act the services act and markets
act um because i believe it's important
to end this sort of digital energy that
you also partially described uh today
but today i'll speak on uh
in my role as sitting in the special
committee on ai because you yourself are
an ai expert
as well um and i think you've you know
largely addressed that topic
in in the remits of the dsa and the dma
but
i think you also have heard that many
have used your very uh helpful as i said
and also brave whistleblowing to ask for
complete fans of ai in various
places when it comes to advertising when
it comes to recommender system or even
systems meant to remove illegal um or
dangerous content
but i believe and also what we've heard
today you have worn against the misuse
of ai uh particularly in the context of
facebook and but i don't have the
impression you're asking for complete
bans um but
rather as you've a number of times
emphasize you're asking for more
transparency to reduce ai usage to where
it makes sense for more sensible
government
regulation and
loss but also for the need for consumers
to be able to make choices which i think
is very important and i conquer on all
of these statements um that you made
because i simply don't believe that all
the work you have been also doing on ai
you would you know
think it's worthy of banning in one way
or or another entirely um but i also
don't think that the the many young and
energetic people that work in startups
in in europe um with ai want to act and
ethically and necessarily
and i think these are the ai developers
that could work on certain issues to
find solutions and this is why i wanted
to hear from you how do we actually
improve the building of the usage of ai
for the benefit of mankind how do we
make sure that we get to these systems
to be safe as you said
and you've elaborated on a number of
points but perhaps you could now go a
little bit while
into the ai itself
and not just into the remits of the dsa
or the dna
do you ever
miss hold on please
um i want to be super clear i don't
advocate for getting rid of ai i'm more
about that especially in a place like
facebook where it is effectively our
communication platform it will be the
personal social media platform for the
foreseeable future that we can only have
a.i if we have more transparency on ai
because right now like for example after
my congressional testimony and mark came
out and said you're worried about
extreme and polarizing content
fine we'll take all political content
out of the news feed
if we don't know how they trained those
systems like what what were the examples
that were considered political what
topics were considered political and we
don't know how those are actually being
used like seeing examples of how things
were classified
like that that can shape our democracies
because they're choosing what ideas can
they can't be distributed anymore um so
i want to be clear i have a game for
transparency not for getting rid of ai
um with regard to how we can make these
systems more generally safer um i think
thinking about how how can we generalize
requiring people to have some visibility
into these systems
um i understand the importance of having
competitive secrets but at the same time
um there are lots of circumstances where
people's lives are pretty dramatically
affected by decisions that are made uh
made by ais and if at a minimum
academics and regulators aren't allowed
at data access
um that that i think is unjust because
the thing that we have seen over and
over again is that these things are
rarely equitable
right that you know african-americans in
the united states are routinely highly
disadvantaged by these systems we see
that today at facebook where on things
like reals
like the ai was never taught racism but
it learned racism by seeing how people
responded to different kinds of content
and it noticed oh african-american
content doesn't get as much engagement
we don't need to show it right so these
are the kinds of things where we need to
have transparency or we'll have like
unjust systems
thank you
i would like to acknowledge that the uk
mp mr damian collins chair of the uk
parliament's joint committee for the
online safety bill is also taking part
in our hearing welcome
mr damon collins
and before starting with the second
round of
questions
i proposed to to make a very short break
it was asked for five minutes but
for only three minutes
so
thank you
break
so
dear colleagues to our guests it seems
we can continue
and we can start with our second round
of
questions and answers first i would like
to ask
pablo arias to take the floor
pablo
is
[Music]
thank you pablo it's hogan please
um
i'll hit on something from the end of
that question first so this question of
you know algorithms are trade secrets
and we have to protect them
any law that allows us to not disclose
data in order to protect trade secrets
is is going to fail right like facebook
is going to do exactly what you
described and they are going to wrap
themselves in trade secrets and say you
know we can't show you any data on our
algorithm because that will violate our
trade secrets
so i think having some some
discretion on that is an important thing
um but with regard to age verification
um i would like to introduce an idea to
you too that may not be obvious which is
there is a difference between a stated
age and an estimated age
so when we shared documents with
congress one of the staffers came back
and said
does this chart mean 10 to 20 of 10 year
olds are on facebook um and it was a
cohort chart it looked at each birth
year
and it using and i looked at i was very
confused initially i was like how could
they know this and then it clicked for
me facebook had gone
and looked at each of those users
friends they looked at their interests
various things and they were able you're
able to with great precision guess what
someone's ages
based on because most most people don't
lie about their age enough kids wait to
join the platform that you can get a
good estimate of what the actual age of
people is
facebook should have to publish
what fraction of people under were under
13 what at what age do they come on the
platform for each cohort so for every
year when kids turn 13 14 facebook can
now publish a backward state and say
what fraction of those people of 14 year
olds on the platform what fraction of
them were on the platform at 10 11 12
because that will allow us to know did
they do a good enough job of keeping
kids off the platform today we don't
have any yardstick we have to just trust
them and so at a minimum i believe they
should have to disclose that estimated
age data
the second question is around how can we
verify kids ages without having to give
up anonymity so anything that requires
us to provide identification i think is
a solution that will fail
because the reality is most places in
the world do not have highly databased
identification
and people as long as they can have a
vpn will go into those other go into
those other countries and register
accounts because facebook's not going to
give up on growth from you know a large
swath of the world
and so if you have any system that is
around you have to verify identity i
think people will just go around it
um
because facebook is also not going to
you know fence in those users and say
you come from africa therefore you can't
talk to people in europe right i i don't
think it'll happen i do think though
there are solutions like um
you can there are now service providers
that you could do this even on a device
it doesn't even have to go to facebook
where taking a picture of someone they
can estimate your age for kids within
about half a year
right and so facebook has lots of tools
it could be using
they should have to publish data that
confirms that you're actually doing
enough
and they should have to also disclose
what are they doing because then
academics independent researchers can
say here are all the other tools that
you might want to use
thank you next uh i would like to invite
evelyn kephart to take the floor
um
[Music]
please
um to be really clear what i said
earlier was that i did not expect
smaller platforms to emerge because
there are
locked in network effects
and that is why the few countries that
did have their own systems
so for personal social media creators
creates they want to reach specific
people
and so the only way you can have
competition is if you could bring that
whole network with you wherever you want
interoperability i think opens up far
bigger problems than we currently have
today and would require a much deeper
level of regulation i'll give you an
example let's all imagine we're email
servers so email has inter
interoperability
but if i want to send an email to
someone on your server i don't have to
broadcast it out to every email server
in the world it just goes to one server
and we have a contract that is easy to
enforce
once an email leaves my server and goes
to your server i can never call it back
i've committed
we have certain expectations with social
media where like let's imagine my
friends scatter across 50 social
networks so there's facebook there's new
book there's new book two new book three
if we have interoperability because uh
we have an expectation that our social
media loads really quickly right if
things don't happen almost
instantaneously people people leave
um
to have interoperability when i post a
picture of my baby on new book
it will get broadcast out to the 50
other platforms that my friends are
scattered across and that sounds fine
you're like oh good now we can all have
our own rankings our own filterings but
it becomes a problem if i ever want to
take that content down so let's say two
years go by and i no longer want
pictures of my children on social media
i have to trust that when my new book
contacts those 50 platforms and says you
need to delete that content that it's
actually deleted
we would have to do a very invasive
level of regulation of all the facebook
clones to ensure that they actually
complied with how they were operating
how do we know that that server wasn't
built by russia right they built a
social network they funded it because
they were never going to delete the
content
right there's a lot of these dangers
where it may not be obvious why
interoperability is is is probably much
more of a mixed bag and much harder to
do in a way that is actually functional
that's part why i advocate for the one
two three approach on risk assessments
and getting transparent access to data
um
with regard to excessively personal
targeted information i think there's
interesting conversations to be had on
how to
simplify those models to try to avoid as
many rabbit holes pushing people towards
them
and with regard to acquisitions i
encourage you to think more broadly than
just the obvious other social platforms
with regard to banning acquisitions by
facebook one of the most important
startups in terms of holding facebook
accountable was crowdtangle
so crowdtangle had a way of of
monitoring what happened on facebook and
facebook bought it
and when
researchers started to notice
how toxic facebook was by using
crowdtangle facebook shuttered that team
like it still exists but they've stopped
developing it and they likely will close
it in the future so when you're thinking
about what acquisitions to not allow to
protect competitiveness or protect
accountability you need to also look at
should facebook be allowed to buy
startups that hold it accountable
because if they buy it they can kill it
and then the last question on data
access and how it can be used i strongly
i'll repeat again i strongly encourage
you to include the independent
researcher community you can have an
accreditation process that's totally
fine but i encourage you to have some
avenue for participation because we need
to build the ecosystem of accountability
because remember you know let's say
someone like me
isn't interested in going to a
university but we're really interested
in running a youtube channel
that could actually inform consumers and
give them choices by translating this
complex complex information into
something they could consume so i
encourage you to be inclusive in who
gets data
thank you
next i would like to ask alicia
schrein among her to take the floor
lisa thank you very much chair and thank
you mrs hogan um for coming here and
sharing your views with us
your revelations have confirmed my
belief that we've let online platforms
make up their own rules and regulations
for too long
and with your call for more transparency
and democratic oversights you are really
preaching to the choir in this house
and i would also like to address the
youngest users of social media platforms
because we know that one in three
internet users is below the age of 18.
we also know that the internet was never
designed with children in mind and while
platforms have opened up many
opportunities for children to learn to
communicate to develop
their design more often than not still
goes after the data of these youngest
users so children are now leaving
digital footprints behind many times the
size of their own shoe size
and besides this use you have also
warned for harmful content that is
served up to these minders
um and i have listened to your answer on
the age verification very clearly and
thank you for this i was very interested
in this but i'm also very interested to
hear how you think that we should really
secure the safety and rights of our
children online and whether you have
concrete proposals to improve platforms
services for children
um and notably in the data processing
and because you have had the chance to
look at the research that facebook has
been done
uh has done do you think that we can
really cater to children and what they
really understand that they are giving
up
uh
in uh trading for uh for free games for
example do they know what they are doing
and can we
uh somehow make this clear to children
so thank you
thank you alicia
miss hogan please
i think it's very important for us to
acknowledge
the
uh
the network of influences that
a child faces when they use things like
instagram so because it is the default
platform for people under 18
uh people uh feel a fear like facebook's
own research says you know kids say
i know it makes me unhappy i know i i i
don't want to use it as much as i do i
can't stop myself and the most important
one and i fear being ostracized if i
leave right that if i leave in isolation
if i make a choice for myself i will be
cut off from my friends and family
people are willing to do some pretty
self-harming things if it means they can
keep their friends right and we see this
with teenagers every day peer pressure
is a real thing
i think it's important when we think
about how to secure the rights of young
people that we keep that in mind that we
really need systems level solutions not
you know blaming parents because kids
use social media
i think one of the most important ways
that we can help protect the rights of
young users is by giving parents better
resources
so one of the things from facebook's
research is that kids because their
parents did not come of age during a
time when instagram was ubiquitous
that you find that parents often give
really harmful advice to their kids or
advice that makes kids feel alone
right so parents will
just say like why don't you just not use
it or they might get angry at their
child because their child can't can't
stop using it and so i think there's a
lot of value in trying to get better
information in the hands of parents so
that
if we can't get the platform safer at
least parents can try to help their kids
more
um
because right now we're expecting
parents to know about neurobiology and
that's unacceptable that's unreasonable
um
with regard to can children understand
what they're trading away
um i think almost certainly kids like we
don't we as adults we don't know what
we've traded away right we don't know
what goes in the algorithms we don't
know how we're targeted so the idea that
children can be give informed consent i
i i don't think we give informed consent
and they have less capability
um
i think there's a real need like in
terms of research to be funded um
one of the things that i'm i'm most
intrigued by is there's a misinformation
researcher out of singapore
and she's an anthropologist and she had
some of the most interesting
observations on how misinformation was
being conducted that we would have never
been able to discover on our own and the
way she found it was by just
interviewing kids
i think funding more research where we
ask kids about their lived experience of
social media is really important because
right now facebook is going to be
discouraged from doing research like
that because
of my disclosure right though i don't
take responsibility for it because their
cowardice is not my fault
and so yeah investing more in listening
to children i think is really valuable
if we want to protect their rights
thank you next i would like to ask
deidra cloon to take the floor
thank you very much and thank you ms
hagan for being with us today um and i
hope this is the start of we'll have
other opportunities as well so thank you
and um i would i'd like one of the
points i wanted to raise actually was
minors and i think the comments you've
made um really
will highlight the fears that so many
parents have
of how their children can be and their
young people can be manipulated um
online and i wanted to ask you if you
were
mr miss facebook making decisions what
would you do how could you change it and
just give us an insight into how
facebook approach um
or they think about their approach
approach to minors
that'd be most interesting and actually
your comments about the dsa i mean um i
think are very encouraging for us i know
i'm just looking at the words we have
describing it as transparency oversight
accountability risk assessment is there
access for researchers even though i
take your point that maybe there's so
many more out there so much more
expertise out there that we could be
availing of asp to to um to data i think
that's all that so that's very very
encouraging i fear that you know
they'll always be one step ahead of us
and so how can we future proof our
legislation and uh bearing in mind it's
not just about facebook it's about other
other platforms as well uh i think that
that would be important for us because
we have a lot of key parameters are
there it's just we need if we can we
never we i know we never will i will
always be behind but really to future
proof i think would be very important
for us and just a small another point i
could ask if facebook changed its
algorithms in 2018 to emphasize um
meaningful social interactions and to
give more weight to uh re-sharing and to
friends
did that work or what happened to that
just
did it work i think i don't think it
probably didn't but just um why was that
decision taken 2018 and did it work so
thank you
thank you miss hogan please
uh with regard to how can we future
proof the dsa um i believe there's a lot
of power in having a one two three
approach so that means they can disclose
risks the community identifies risks
because listening to different groups is
going to give us more things that we
need to flag and facebook should propose
solutions but
we should hold them accountable that
those are rigorous solutions and they
should disclose data that would allow us
to track progress on those solutions if
you don't have all three parts i don't
think it'll be effective but if you do
have all three parts developing that
cycle
where data is continuously disclosed
that's something we need to mod that i
think i encourage you to modify the dsa
if they pull data for you once
it's easy for them to pull it every week
because they have already written the
queries to pull that information so if
they tell you it's too onerous to do it
twice a year guess what giving you a
stream where they just re-run the same
queries every week it's it's very little
additional work for them so don't
i encourage you to be questionable in
them
that process of having uh building an
ecosystem of contributors having data
that regularly comes out so we can
monitor when step changes happen because
i i i saw over and over again at
facebook that they would have
regressions that a feature would launch
that no one could have anticipated was
going to greatly amplify misinformation
but i guarantee you if 10 000 people
were watching those streams
they would notice that something had
changed and so it is important to build
the ecosystem
so the next question is around msi so
msi was done specifically for business
interests so they claimed they wanted to
increase meaningful social interactions
but those interactions could have been
hate speech it could have been bullying
today they only fixed that part for
english in november 2020 right if you
did bullying or hate speech in the
comments they still count it as a
meaningful social interaction and for
the vast majority of languages in the
world today and i guarantee you a
majority of european languages you can
do hate speech in the comments today and
still look considered a meaningful
social interaction the reason why
facebook did that change was they had
tried many many things to get people to
produce more content because people were
starting to produce less and less
because it was so toxic
and what they found was the only thing
that worked and that had the least side
effects was giving you more little hits
of dopamine
that if you got more likes more comments
more reshares you produced more content
and they ran experiments on creators to
figure this out
when they went and did surveys after the
fact so six months down the line they
found that people said their feeds were
less meaningful after they implemented
meaningful social interactions
because like we have talked about
repeatedly during today's session
when you prioritize for content that can
provoke a reaction
you
end up biasing towards extreme
polarizing divisive content
we have seen political parties picked up
on this publishers picked up on this
like facebook's own research says that
when you use engagement based ranking
like this you end up seeing that
the more toxic your comment thread is
like the more negative the common thread
is the more likely they click out to
your site
and i guarantee you publishers notice
this
right
buzzfeed which is a large large outline
in the united states they wrote to
facebook and said
the content that we're the least proud
of is the content that gets the most
distribution on facebook you clearly
have a problem
but because they needed it to get people
to keep creating content that's why they
kept captain in place
thank you
next i would like to ask kim von
sparanthak to take the floor king
the floor thank you very much and also
thank you to madame hogan for being here
today
um i think you've explained it very
clearly for years facebook has profited
from the large scale spread of this
information and hate
and what we see online is driven by
clicks interaction and profit
and this means recommender algorithms
are programmed to show people content
that sparks anger hate and even sends
people down rabbit holes of
radicalization
facebook knows the impact of their
algorithm but refuses to do anything
about it and this only reaffirms what we
already know it's time for strong rules
my group the greens and i fully agree
with you that to hold companies
accountable we have to know what is
actually going on
we need to understand in detail how
these algorithmic systems work how they
are optimized and how they are
influenced
only then we can take the power over
what happens online out of the hands of
private companies and place it firmly
back in the hands of the people
but tech companies and some right-wing
politicians frame such transparency as
an unreasonable burden for companies and
you've already also touched upon this
trade secrets issue
so my first question is could you
explain to us how feasible it is to have
transparency of recommender algorithms
and reporting on content moderation for
companies
and yeah knowing what happens is a
crucial first step but holding platforms
accountable and giving users more
control is the next step
transparency alone will not be enough if
people cannot act upon this information
and if nobody holds platforms
accountable so my second question to you
is how do you think we can empower
people and give the public more control
over what they see online and which role
could independent oversight researchers
and civil society play as a part of the
solution thank you
thank you miss hogan please
so with regard to how feasible is it for
them to provide data
i think it's important for us to
differentiate between the first time
they do it and the ongoing times it is
likely that for the foreseeable future
many of the things that are flagged via
the risk assessment will continue to be
problems
right and so yes the first time they may
need to write that the way we get data
out of these systems is via a query
right we query the system they will have
to write many queries likely the first
time though many of them will be things
they already have
they will already run this analysis
somewhere and they have at least
facebook has a search engine that lets
them find those queries
each additional time
it is likely that they won't have to
write as many queries because many of
the problems are likely going to stay
the same time to time we might need to
ask slightly different questions of what
information we would need to know to get
progress because likely once that data
is published once those streams are
released every week ongoing basis that
people will begin to say oh interesting
actually i wanted it a little bit
different and the next time around you
can tweak it
um
we are we're not asking for something
unreasonable this is something that
facebook can totally provide and i think
the thing that is exciting to me is i
think actually having more transparency
on data would likely bring more
employees to facebook when i worked at
yelp
um i was really sh
struck by how did yelp staff itself so
yelp is one of the only companies that
releases a real user data set it shows
you reviews from i think it's like 15
college towns in the united states
and it's used across the united states
across the world as a data set to teach
people machine learning to teach them
how to analyze language computationally
and a huge fraction of yelp's employees
said the reason i decided to work at
yelp
why i did an internship at yelp was
because i took a class where i used
yelp's data and i was so intrigued by
what i found that i chose to work here
i think one of the top challenges for
facebook is that people don't want to
work there right now they are in a
feedback cycle where because they've cut
corners they have scandals which makes
it harder to hire which makes them
cut more corners which causes more
scandals
this is just getting worse and
unfortunately what i my disclosure will
likely make it worse too
i think there's a real thing that if you
know more young people
were exposed to these data streams in
college classes and i guarantee you
college classes will be taught about
these data streams especially if they
come out weekly
monthly whatever is the appropriate
frequency to still protect privacy and i
think it might light a generation on
wanting to work on facebook i think
there's a real opportunity there
with regard to improving control control
is really hard in isolation so if we
just let people opt into having a
different ranking there's major
limitations with that because for
example i often endorse what i call
chronological plus plus so ordering by
time but having intelligible
modifications like if you post a lot if
you spam demoting people that's the
thing that we can
can actually understand by looking at as
humans
if you just do that change but you don't
change any of the other things about the
product
it won't work right because facebook has
pushed people into million person groups
and they will get spammed by the group
right it's about changing features in
concert and i think when you have a risk
assessment that's like a one two three
style
facebook will have to think more
holistically about how to solve these
problems i also think it's um
dangerous to expect individuals to
understand these issues enough when
they're so complicated that they would
adequately be able to protect themselves
if you just have a thing where if people
choose between two different rankings
and like and one's a lot more fun
like people will opt for
the hyper-optimized one that has all
facebook has all the data and all the
control on
and so i i don't think users will get
the product that they deserve um if we
just expect you know the market to sell
for it
thank you next i would like to ask marco
campo manosi to take the floor but i
have a bad news so it seems that we will
not have time for cure for catching the
eye the session
if those questions will be shorter and
answers will be also shorter then maybe
but now it seems that no catch in the
eye
so
marco please
thank you very much thank you to be here
[Music]
i think that the most important question
is also
who is
entitled to define what is a fake news
or when we are in front of a violation
and i'm convinced that the public
authority has to take this role
but it's important also that you know
which is the situation in europe because
for fiscal reasons the major
platforms are all based in ireland
and the irish authorities cannot
give an answer to all the procedures
that 99 percent of the appeals are not
prosecuted
and the eu member states national
authorities have to find back doors in
order to solve this question
the italian authority on data protection
had to intervene on tick-tock regarding
an important issue which was
the way
of the consent given by children with
less than 14 years old
and they had to find the so-called
utensil procedure given by article 66 of
gdpr regulation
a german authority did the same on
another topic and also the belgian
authority has been authorized in order
to solve the question because if not it
was not possible to do elsewhere
of course i told you i i think public
authorities have to intervene but of
course we have also to intervene on on
the platforms um
we have on one side the risk in having
an intervention which is too strict
there is to have on one side over
blocking
the creation of filter bubbles
or the
complete cut of a political debate
facebook does not want to anymore to
have a political debate it's not
business for them on the other side
stricter rules could
could be
and become a barrier
for the possibility for startups to
enter in this special market
and this is also as legislator something
on which we should intervene and i hope
that this will be done i don't know if
you have an opinion on this topic thank
you very much
thank you miss hogan please
okay i'm a strong proponent for having
tiered regulations um because you're
right like startups have less resources
to execute
in systems like this but in a world
where facebook will be the only form of
personal media like large-scale personal
media social media for the foreseeable
future
i think having exemptions or like having
higher standards for facebook or like in
the case of google for advertising i
think that's appropriate
so having tiers for regulations i think
is really valuable for that reason
um with regard to the challenges of
having enforcement be all
giving ireland the burden of having to
enforce all these rules because you're
right most the tech companies are out of
ireland um i think there's a real real
need
um for there to be some kind of
centralized authority in europe because
like i said before like if there's only
maybe 200 or 300 people in the industry
who have enough experience and insight
around how these systems work and what
the consequences of them are
if we expect to
spread them across 27 agencies
i think that's it's going to be very
ineffective like it's not you're not
going to get the critical mass in any
one place
um i think there is also that conflict
of interest factor that ireland benefits
a lot from having those tech companies
there and i think it puts them under
unfair pressure to have to
hold those things in tension because i'm
sure ireland cares about the safety of
our children ireland cares about our
democracies being threatened but they
also have um extreme pressures being
exerted against them which shows the
need for a central
central oversight
thank you
next i would like to ask maria manuel
marquez to take the floor please
thank you thank you francis for what you
have done and for being here today with
us and let me go straight to my
questions
facebook papers prove facebook now meta
knows its causing harm and choose not to
act
therefore we must have hard regulation
to guide innovation away from hurtful
results as you are doing in europe last
week i was in washington having meetings
with the congress and the white house
and i felt a large gap between the u.s
and eu approach to regulation in your
view how should we bridge this gap and
create a democratic model to the digital
ecosystem
who has to move closer to the other
i also want to talk about business model
we can't expect different outcomes
without change to the business model
as zuckerberg said senator we sell apps
so it's not surprised that i'm referring
to ads and micro targeting and
behavioral advertising in particular
social media cells as an utopia given
enough diet it will perfectly pared
predict the behavior of users and match
it with the products being sold to them
to the benefit of users and business
alike
however
what we have is a dystopia not only
there is little evidence of benefits for
businesses but we ended up with an
industry of surveillance and mass data
collection that gives rise to
vulnerabilities for individuals groups
and even political systems
you say
you
would like to give people choices i
agree but it's more subtle than that
first i don't think people really are
able to consent to data collection and
use it
and use with full knowledge of
what that means what data who is
collecting how they are using it and
second even if i choose to share my own
data
that will contain information about the
people i interact with
so i shouldn't it shouldn't really be
only my choice some of azeri and
parliament think we need to put a stop
to micro targeting and behaviorally
advertising and the data collection that
it implies
i would like very much to hearing from
you about this proposal thank you very
much
thank you miss hogan please
i think there's a large opportunity to
bring the united states and the european
union closer together
in that you know what i've said
repeatedly is that i don't support
having a regulator that comes in and
says we know how to do social media
better than facebook
but i do believe that consumers have the
right to know what they're actually
using
and the thing about risk assessments
especially risk assessments that are
publicly published and having data where
we can independently verify that they're
actually making progress is it allows
people to make choices on the products
they use
that's really really important and i
think that idea the idea that the
regulator's job is to make sure that
facebook's telling the truth
and like has a process where they have
to they actually have to reflect on
what's happening and you know the thing
that's great is if facebook doesn't
exhibit progress then people actually
get a choice on whether or not they want
to keep using it or they can put other
forms of pressure on facebook facebook
has hidden this data because they know
it's bad right they know that if more
people knew it was actually happening on
the platform they would put more
pressure to change facebook and i think
that kind of lens where you say hey this
is not so much about a regulator telling
you what to do and more about you should
just have to be honest about what you're
doing and we're going to make sure we
have a process where every six months
you have to come clean
i think that's a thing that a lot of
people in the united states could sign
on for
right um
because you know there's more of a bias
in the united states of like at least
you know you can't have a free market if
people don't know what they're buying we
have for example
nutritional policies where people have
to publish the ingredients on their food
it's the same thing we're just asking
for the information ingredients in this
case
with regard to choices um
you know in the case of um
tracking on apple products so apple
recently forced um advertiser for forced
apps to disclose like do they do
tracking and make people opt-in to it
it's something like 80 percent of people
choose not to opt in
so the question is around making sure we
don't have dark patterns that force
people into systems
and i do agree with you on this question
of like often my actions might bleed
information about my friends
but i think if we required
platforms like facebook to disclose what
goes into their ad targeting then we
would know whether or not they're using
factors that would cause that kind of
bleed over
with regard to micro targeting
i think there are specific
things and ads that really need to be
regulated so for example given the
current system subsidizes hate you know
it's five to ten times cheaper to run a
political ad that's hateful than a
non-hateful ad i think you need to have
flat rates for ads i think that's
definitely a thing
but i also think there should be
regulation on targeting ads to specific
people so i don't know if you're aware
of this but right now you can target
specific ads to an audience of a hundred
people
and i'm pretty sure this is being
misused because i did analysis on who is
hyper exposed to political ads
and unsurprisingly the people who are
most exposed are in washington dc
and they are radically overexposed we're
talking thousands of political ads a
month
and so i do think having mechanisms to
target specific people um without their
knowledge i think is is unacceptable
thank you next speaker is nicolas pexa
nicholas
thank you
uh miss hogan uh first let me thank you
for you coming here today and for your
bravery in standing up against the
practices that encourage hate and
division in our society
however we are not here only to listen
and try to understand what went wrong in
one of the most influential social media
companies in the world
we are also here to find a way forward
so i would like to hear your opinion on
the following questions uh first in your
view what can the european union do to
better protect legally whistleblowers
especially in big multinational
companies like facebook is
secondly
the current proposal for the digital
services act as i put forward in the
economic and monetary affairs committee
suggests that the recommender system
should have a clear option to be used
without personal profiling
how do you see this change will it help
to alleviate the issues connect with the
current practice of driving for higher
engagement through conflict uh between
the users
certainly
regarding data profiling and data
retention platforms are profiling users
collecting and analyzing their every
action
building up their profiles and then
creating algorithms to make them stay
longer on the platform in order to make
them more emotionally invested
do you believe this is appropriate or
even ethical
and
lastly your public statements have
revealed a lot of inner working of
facebook uh however we cannot solely
rely on the on mr blowers we also need
much more systemic transparency
do you consider the proposed provisions
on transparency of algorithms for public
and ngos
open research and independent oversight
sufficient
or should europe be more ambitions i
mean in sense of legal
law making thanks for for any opinions
you couldn't share with us
thank you miss holden please
with regard to
whistleblower protections uh i i believe
that there is a need for stronger
whistleblower protections across the eu
because not all member states have
whistleblower protections
um and i want to and even in the united
states for example in the united states
i was protected under the the securities
and exchange commission because i worked
for a public company
had i worked for tick-tock and had the
same information i would have had no
i would have no legitimate way to bring
forward that information or wouldn't
have the same protections
there's a need for protecting both
public and private employees
there's also a need for having more
on-ramps to disclosure
if i had driven a bus in the united
states or worked at a hospital there
would have been a phone number that was
legally mandated to be in my break room
that said did you see something that
endangered public safety call this
number someone will take you seriously
well and you'll be you'll be safe
nothing like that exists in europe and
nothing exists like that in the united
states i had concerns about national
security because i was working on
counter espionage i think facebook has
radically underinvested in major
national security issues and i'm happy
to talk to any of you about this later
um
and i had no i had no idea on who i
could talk to and i think that's really
i think the human cost of that is
something that's hard to understand
where when you have to hold a secret
that you know is jeopardizing people's
lives and you have no way to reconcile
that that destroys people and i watched
that happen to my co-workers
with regard to profiling and data
retention
i think it shouldn't you shouldn't be
allowed to take third party data sources
something facebook does they work with
credit card companies other forms
and it makes their ads radically more
profitable i don't think you should i
think you should have to consent every
time you hook up more data sources
because i think people would feel really
uncomfortable if they knew facebook had
some of the data that they do and
there's people who aren't even on
facebook who i've i i don't know if this
is a current thing but i've watched
documentaries and read articles where
they say they have shadow profiles for
people who aren't yet on the platform
where because they have these sources
like credit card data and things like
that they can form profiles on people
and lastly on this question of can you
be more ambitious with data i think
having a process that is dynamic where
we change our data asks over time and we
match them to problems
people often get fixated on the idea
that we need raw data we need access to
all the raw data
and as someone who has done a lot of
data analysis of social media networks
raw data i think opens a lot of a can of
worms around privacy um and is very hard
to work with like the scale of
facebook's data is is just
amazing having a system where people we
assess problems both on by facebook and
by the community that's the one and the
two
and we have to publish aggregate data
that would show progress
i i think a lot of learnings and and um
our ability to understand how these
systems work would happen as a side
effect of the data we ask for because
there's often many many questions you
can answer with a set of data not just
the original one that you asked
thank you next i would like to ask rob
ross to take the floor please
thank you chair and a special thank you
to you uh ms hogan for being uh here
with us today
thank you for your presentation and your
courage to bring out the information you
have revealed i know from my own
experience that it's much easier to
remain silent than to speak out
miss hogan i have suffered several
concerns and hope your answers will help
us to tackle these very important
challenges i listen to your presentation
and your appearance in the media and i
wonder what you see as the biggest
problem is it misinformation or is the
algorithm showing targeted
misinformation to specific users making
them addicted to the platform and
further polarizing our society
i ask this because regulating
transparency about algorithm algorithms
is probably easier to address than
topics as misinformation and also hate
speech i understand that these forms of
information can be a real problem but
the definitions are at the end of the
day somewhat
arbitrary
and i also fear
a world where users can only take notice
of the official truth should we include
in the dsa that platforms give users an
option to completely opt out of any
content suggested by algorithms so by
giving users the possibility to choose
for a real timeline without any
suggestion by algorithms of the platform
or the platform
in addition i have an open question it
is it has to do with the mental side
effect of instagram and this is a major
problem with even resulting in suicide
by young girls do you have suggestions
on what we should do to tackle that
problem thank you very much
thank you miss holden please
i have repeated frequently that i don't
believe the problem with facebook is bad
people or bad content is about a system
that progres like consistently has a
bias towards amplifying giving the
largest reach to the most extreme and
divisive content
that's that's the real problem here um
facebook has known this since at least
2018 when they rolled out meaningful
social interactions they know that is
influenced publishers it's influenced
political parties and they know there's
a recurrent problem on their platforms
so i think it's about the system and
this is systematic choices
i think this idea of allowing people to
opt out of algorithms i i think people
should have more control for example
there was an independent person who
wrote an extension that allowed you to
unfollow things
something that most people are not aware
of is facebook right now if you are
invited to a group
and in the case of invites to groups
because their rate limits are so high
um the top person that invited people to
q anon groups invited 300 000 people to
q and on groups they did not consent to
being invited but facebook
then inserted content from those groups
into their feed so imagine someone comes
along and says we're going to help you
unfollow things that you're following
and it's me one click
facebook threaten to sue that person
right because they know they need to
keep you in those systems if you're
going to consume enough content they
don't want you choosing what you look at
they want to feed you that content
i don't though support uh allowing
people just to opt out of using
algorithms because you can't disentangle
product choices and algorithms so for
example if people don't opt out of all
those groups they're in or unfollow you
know a variety of things
you'll you'll now get spammed by those
mega groups
right so
if you are a member of a million person
group you'll get a fire hose of all the
content from that group every day and so
just opting out the algorithm won't
solve the problems that we're we're
discussing right now
lastly on the mental effects for
teenagers um or mental health mental
health effects overall because something
that i don't think has been talked about
enough is the role of facebook on things
like depression
right one of the top risk factors for
being overexposed to misinformation is
being recently widowed or recently
divorced
or moving to a new city so facebook is
showing the most misinformation to
people who are already socially isolated
and i think that's problematic they know
that being depressed makes you consid it
correlates with you consuming more
content on facebook but in the case of
teenagers
i think a lot of the problems around
things like eating disorders are just
repeat they're just more echoes of the
same pattern
that when you follow moderate interest
engagement based ranking pulls you
towards extreme interests and they've
seen this over and over again they can
create a new account they can follow
center left or center right content and
you'll get pushed to the far left in the
far right and that's another thing that
will tear our democracy apart and so it
really is about systemic problems and
how do we address these systematic like
these systemic risks
thank you next speaker is timo welcome
team of the lawyers please thank you
very much chair first of all i would
like to thank you uh for your courage
for standing up for what you believe in
and for sharing your knowledge with us
here in the european parliament and
answering so many questions so i'm
convinced that your insights can indeed
change the course of
the negotiations on the digital services
act and help making it a true digital
constitution for our european citizens
so you made clear how important it is
that we tackle social media algorithms
there can be no place in europe for
algorithms that promote disinformation
and hate over sober political debate and
high quality information for profit
reasons i really believe that so we need
to break the harmful monopoly of big
platforms like facebook over our
attention
so in my view this monopoly rests on two
aspects
uh content recommendation and
personalized advertising so the
recommender algorithms are used to keep
us on the platform for as long as
possible at any cost so that the
advertising algorithms can feed us the
highly personalized personalized ads to
finance the whole operation so my
question would be
and how far are those two sets of
algorithms connected the ones used for
recommendation of content and the ones
used for advertising should we approach
them together or do you think we could
solve most issues by focusing on one of
the other
the papers
another question this information so the
papers you shared
included a striking figure so and you
mentioned it today in 2020 facebook
allocated 87 percent of its budget for
devo developing its misinformation
detection algorithms to the us and only
13 to the rest of the world this
suggests that facebook prefers to focus
on the english speaking world
what can we in europe do to force
facebook and others to pay more
attention to what is happening here so
do you think we need dedicated
legislation to deal with that um yeah i
have of course a lot of more questions
but i uh keep it for for this for now
and thanks again for being here with us
and for helping us to make the digital
europe safe
thank you timo uh miss hogan please
i strongly believe that europe has a
critical role to play in regulating
these platforms because you are a
vibrant
linguistically diverse democracy
there are real problems with having
systems that
we're having a company that can overlook
a language because there are only 5
million speakers of it
i guarantee you there are european
languages or even within larger
countries dialects and remember ai is so
brittle it's so fragile a dialect i'm
guessing uk english doesn't get anywhere
near as much actual efficacy as u.s
english because it's enough different
that ai then breaks
right um so i think there's a deep deep
need to make sure that platforms must
disclose
what safety systems they have what
languages those safety systems are in
and the performance per language and
that's the kind of thing where you can
put in the dsa you can say you need to
be honest with us on is this actually
dangerous for a large fraction of
europeans because when you do
legislation like that you actually end
up protecting the rest of the world too
because it will force facebook towards
language neutral content neutral
solutions
um because that's how what will scale it
also speaks up for people who live in
fragile places in the world that don't
have as much influence right the places
in the world that have the most
linguistic diversity are often the most
fragile um places and and they need
europe to step in because you guys have
influence and you can help you can
really help them um
and that includes things like they
should publish the content taken down
per language it should be how many
staffers are actually protecting german
elections or protecting french elections
um it should be things like uh how many
staff like how many moderators are in
each language what's the latency for a
review in each language because that
will be the only way we can have an
equitable system
with regard to on the monopoly being
driven by content recommendations or
advertising um i don't think you will be
able to um
like just having a lot of people to swap
in and out recommendation systems i
don't think will be effective because
facebook's whatever one facebook
controls
because they control the rest of the
product changes and they can have all
the data
they will have a much more enjoyable or
addictive experience than anyone else
will and so if you allow people to
choose their system
also it's a question on business model
it's likely the only way you can make a
business that could have its own ranking
system is if you charge a subscription
as facebook has shown in places like
the lesser developed world
if you charge for
other choices and facebook is free
people overwhelmingly choose facebook
and so i i think it's really a thing if
we need to have accountability and
transparency on how facebook works then
assuming that we can have other choices
and the choices are going to be what
helps us
thank you
next i would like to ask big tipper to
take to the floor please
thank you very much chair and thanks mrs
hogan for casting the light on the
business model of facebook and you
clearly advocate for accountability for
transparency and public scrutiny as we
do in the labor committee and in
parliament and therefore allow me
some questions first of all you already
raised some concerns and criticisms
regarding the use of automatic tools for
content management management and
content filters as they cannot reliably
identify illegal content
resulting in suppression of legal
content do you believe in this context
that the addition of human review could
be a solution
second
one of the most important safeguards to
all our digital communication of course
is encryption
and on the one hand the european
commission announced that it generally
does not want to weaken encryption but
again and again we have debates about
backdoors
now we heard about facebook's wider
plans regarding end-to-end encryption
does it mean that facebook users can be
sure that their privacy
is actually protected and do you believe
that the millions of users communication
is safe and confidential
now
thirdly on the dsa a lot of debates are
around the regulation of advertising
and i think the current practices of
personalized targeting should be
replaced by contextual advertising
and regarding the targeting for
commercial advertising one idea is this
should only be possible where users have
freely opt-in with a limited time to
ensure that the once given consent
cannot be exploited what are your views
what facebook's reactions will be if
this were legally required
and finally again and again we have
debates about data retention meaning
providers have to collect and store data
for years and years having in mind
facebook's dominance on the market and
regarding all the debates we heard not
only today do you think this is the
right approach to give more powers to
facebook and other providers thank you
thank you but uh
i would like also to ask
might
to take the floor and then we will take
calls at the last question and then i
would like to ask miss hogan to respond
thank you
for
thank you and the last speaker is ivan
garcia del blanco please
the last but not the least uh thank you
very much for being here
miss hogan
i'm going to speak in spanish from this
moment so
so please take the
headphones
off
[Music]
yes
thank you it's 1931 already and it means
i have to
thank cory cordially our interpreters
thank you very much
and now i would like to ask miss hogan
to take the floor
how much time do i have do i only get
two minutes now for those three sorry
time is over but uh yeah i'll do this
i'll do it as fast as i can i'll do as
fast as i can um
okay
um okay so with regard to human review
because two of you asked about it um i
human part of why facebook doesn't do
enough human reviews human review does
not scale when they talk about having 40
000 moderators they have 3.1 billion
uh users like it's just not possible to
have humans review enough of the content
um that's why i advocate for making
these systems more human scale less
opportunities for mass distribution to a
million people and
finding more ways that humans moderate
each other
versus having ai do it
with regard to encryption
i'm really concerned that facebook
should publish what is it doing in terms
to implement uh encryption because when
you give people a false sense of safety
they can actually put themselves at
jeopardy and so forcing facebook to
disclose like what are the safety
systems how do they work because we saw
with a whistleblower prior to my my my
sec filing which is a week before that
they felt that facebook had not
adequately communicated how safety
systems worked on whatsapp and that
people would be surprised
so i think having that level of
transparency is really essential
um
with regard to
uh in
[Music]
let's see
i do worry about this concept of
addiction or things that are are drawing
people in um there were two comments
around the hours and hours that people
spend on these platforms i think this is
true across all platforms i think you
should have to disclose by percentile
and and not just by percentile for
extreme users so this is the top one
percent maybe by tenth of a percentile
how many hours do people spend on these
systems per week
because the real problem on a lot of
these things for the harms involved is
that as people get exposed to targeted
misinfo or the misinfo of these
concentrated communities they get cut
off from the rest of reality right that
when you begin to believe beliefs that
are not consent consent like beliefs
that are the consensus norms it makes it
harder for you to reintegrate into
society and you pull people into these
these rabbit holes
so i think disclosing how much time
people are spending is going to be
important especially for the metaverse
for those of you who are not familiar
with the novel snow crash which is where
the phrase the metaverse came from
specifically talked about in that book
i'm i'm shocked they picked this name in
that book the meta the metaverse is a
dystopian thing that people's lives are
so unpleasant that they need to hide in
the system for half of the half of their
day
i think that's what's going to happen
you're going to have people who are
disconnected from society or
marginalized and you're going to have
people getting pulled into these virtual
worlds because they are really addictive
they are really compelling they give
people a sense of agency when they might
not have it in their real lives and i
think requiring uh publishing or having
people disclose like do they feel like
they're they're in control we have to
have ways of getting uh research and
governance on these things
with regard to
um
the quantity of data delivered in the
case of the metaverse i'm very concerned
about that we talked about before that
these systems require having even more
sensors in our life and the issue i'm
even more concerned about is if they're
trying to aim for the workplace people
don't get to consent in their workplaces
in the same way and so i worry about the
idea of facebook forming profiles on us
where people can't even opt out because
it's between their livelihood and
their privacy
um
i highly encourage this idea on um for
for opting in on personalized targeting
there should be time limits
because people should be able to make
different choices over time and i
strongly encourage having that be
time-bounded and i think the last one
i'm going to comment on
data retention so something that
facebook definitely takes advantage of
is they no longer retain data beyond 90
days
that actually has some pretty serious
security implications so
a thing that we found across when i was
working with the threat investigators
was that often it was hard to see how
things like influence networks evolved
or the impact of terrorism recruiting
because we could only see back 90 days
the only way you got to have data over
time was if you uh you intentionally
flagged that person and so it became
difficult to actually track the
evolution of some of these systems
um and so i think there are uh
there should be questions around
how data retention works i'm not saying
keep it for years but maybe more than 90
days would be helpful maybe six maybe
six months or something yeah that's why
thank you so much for your time i'm
incredibly grateful that the european
union is taking this seriously i think
you guys are really a light in the
darkness like i feel confident that you
guys are gonna pass a law that has teeth
that it has dynamic ways of adjusting
over time
because we need that we are going to
need oversight on these platforms more
and more with time they have far too
much power in our society to be able to
operate in the dark and facebook is
shown they will not give us any data
unless we force them to the last thing i
want to drop in there before my six
minutes expires is facebook has shown
that they will lie with data and so i
encourage you to put in the dsa
if facebook gives you data they should
have to show you how they got it
because we have had multiple scandals
where facebook says they've given out
data but because every data analysis
requires assumptions
facebook makes assumptions and then
doesn't disclose them so we think we
know what data we're looking at but in
reality they are misleading us
they have the best data scientists in
the world they can dance with data
unlike anyone else and it's really
really important that they should have
to disclose the process the queries the
notebooks they use to pull this data
because you can't trust anything they
give you unless you can confirm them
thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you alfredo thank you very much
for being with us to hear
this
evening i would like to thank all the
speakers i would like to thank all the
members of the parliament at our guest
taking part in this hearing
this fundamental piece of legislation on
what our digital economies based in the
european union is e-commerce directing
all those main principles country forage
in principle limited liability
liability principle
prohibition of generator general
monitoring or coming from e-commerce
directive but we got to this
e-commerce directive already 20 years
ago at that time we didn't have the
social media platforms we didn't have
sharing economy
platform
platforms and it's absolutely clear we
have to update this e-commerce directive
and our digital services act is dealing
exactly
with those issues so i'm absolutely sure
that uh all our members of the
parliament that they got a lot of pros
and contras and now
they are
more confident in in their decisions
than before this hearing
once again thank you very much for being
here with with us today
next meeting will take place on the 1st
of december of this year thank you
[Music]
you